Memorial Day is a time for Americans to
remember more than a million men and
women in uniform who have died serving
our country thousands of motorcycles
roared through Washington yesterday in
the annual ride for freedom the
nonprofit advocacy group Rolling Thunder
saluted military members missing in
action and the service is scheduled
today at the Vietnam Veterans Memorial
the black granite slabs feature the
names of more than 58,000 Americans lost
during the Vietnam War visitors often
leave behind personal mementos for their
loved ones and comrades ship reads at
the wall with the tributes that helped
many people find closure chip good
morning well good morning hundreds of
people have already walked by here this
morning and as you can see behind me
through the people's legs they've left
everything from flags to letters to
photographs over here even a teddy bear
it's all part of the effort to honor
every single name on that wall
[Music]
the granite wall in the names etched in
it elicits a wide range of responses
some stand in silence others pray or
offer a final salute hi David welcome
home
many feel compelled to leave offerings
of love or gratitude or remembrance a
pair of boots photographs letters even a
last cigarette each evening National
Park Service Rangers collect the items
and send them here a massive warehouse
in Maryland filled to the rafters with
objects left since 1982 he has been
missing in action
Ranger Janet fo Kurtz catalogs the items
and keeps them in pristine condition do
you know the total number of objects we
we don't know the total we have a guess
around 400,000 hundred thousand yes we
never will feel it fully no until we
have everything catalogued which we
don't have which could take a very long
time yeah
they range from works of art to dog tags
to a motorcycle this Harley was left at
the wall by the Wisconsin chapter of
Rolling Thunder a Vietnam veteran
advocacy group to remember the 37
Wisconsin Vietnam veterans missing in
action each item is treated with
reverence but foal Kurtz says some it
harder than others this is a letter from
somebody who was engaged to somebody who
went to Vietnam and he passed away
Warren officer James Bosley didn't come
home his fiance Carol left with a ring
and charmbracelet wrote dear Jim you are
still the 21 year old chopper pilot
curly-haired blue-eyed and oh so
handsome the ring and bracelet symbolize
our youth and what might have been I
really identify with the lady who wrote
it just imagining my fiance or know my
husband going and not being able to fill
all of our dreams that we had it for our
future it does pack a punch okay we'll
need a lot we want to have that visceral
representation Jason Bayne is a curator
with the Vietnam Veterans Memorial
Foundation he's working with the Park
Service to select items from the
collection for an educational center to
be built near the wall what we have here
infant Slayer soon after the wall was
built this baby sweater was left by the
mother of private first class
Donald Detmer I wanted to bring you
teddy bear but just couldn't part with
it instead I brought your first sweater
you were always in my heart how I love
you and that's typical of the kind of
thing you find here some of those early
objects what we like to refer to as
close to the loss are just just packed
with that that raw emotion other items
like this care package are haunting
reminders of families suffering
unbearable loss this care package
arrived in country just about the time
that specialist for Stewart was killed
in action and unfortunately it was
simply stamped with this date ki a
killed in action killed in action and
was sent home to his family and that's
what they saw and that's what his family
saw years later Stewart's family left
the package at the wall says Charles
Stewart mom and dad wants you to have
these cookies and kool-aid it's time
they gave these to you they send all
their love Gary be some items left
behind reflect the deep longing for
closure felt by many Vietnam veterans
one left this photograph Delta 71 your
face haunts me and the name is gone so
this photo was left by someone who knew
him by how he looks but didn't know
which name was his on the wall couldn't
identify him couldn't take a name
rubbing in a way couldn't complete that
experience and I think for us that's
really the mission for Vivi MF it's it's
to connect the faces to the name bein
hopes putting the objects on display
along with photos of the Fallen will
help veterans families and the nation to
heal it will give visitors to the
Education Center and I think visitors to
the wall a bit more depth of that
experience to to not just read the names
but to see these faces and to to
understand that these were real people
real human beings who had lives or
culture they're still raising money for
the Vietnam War Education Center but the
plan is to build it across the road and
underground so it won't interfere with
the visual experience of visiting the
wall and in addition to the thousands of
objects that will be on display
they also hope to include photographs of
every single person whose name is on
this wall
Dana Oh chip chip Reid with a wonderful
story there I mean you look at that the
last words there the idea that it would
be personalized everybody can sort of
associate now not just see a name as I
covered the opening of the Vietnam
Veterans Memorial in 1982 it was then
and it is now one of the most moving
places you could ever go just in all
those names may immediately make it
personal but there are always objects at
that wall that people leave yeah it's so
touching 58,000 American heroes very
special piece there from chip thank you
chip especially to remember today that
is what today is about remembering those
who paid the ultimate sacrifice